Welcome back everyone is Charlie so this
morning if you didn't see the internet
was going crazy because everyone thinks
that Henry Cavill is going to be the new
version of Wolverine in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I'll explain why
that is and what's really going on with
x-men during Marvel phase 4 because even
though some of the rumors you might hear
aren't true there is x-men stuff
happening during Marvel phase 4 if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's going to be a bunch of big stuff
coming up we're doing that big infinity
saga box set giveaway for all the
blu-rays all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with the x-men during
Marvel phase 4 so we'll just break this
down top 5 style starting with number 5
if you didn't see it earlier today a
bunch of websites and low-level blogs
were reporting that Henry Cavill was
going to play Wolverine in Captain
Marvel 2 of all movies which Marvel is
getting ready to film next year we know
that Captain Marvel 2 is happening
they've already confirmed it but already
you should start seeing some red flags
when you hear Captain Marvel 2 in
Wolverine mentioned in the same sentence
but naturally the internet did the thing
that it always does when a fan favorite
actor everybody loves henry cavill is
rumored to be playing such a popular
character that everyone has been
wondering about for a couple years now
since Hugh Jackman said that he wasn't
going to be doing Wolverine anymore of
course everyone wants to know what's
going to happen with the future of the
Wolverine character so a little while
after that what happened was is that a
ton of higher-level legitimate news
websites picked up the rumor and it's
sort of spreading like wildfire without
anyone really bothering to get
confirmation even websites like just
jerod in Entertainment Tonight Canada
legitimate websites that post behind the
scene pictures for major movies and do a
lot of legitimate coverage of stuff did
whole articles about Henry Cavill
Wolverine written as if he were actually
going to be doing it thankfully most of
you probably saw the headlines did a
double-take and had the good sense to
realize that it's probably not true for
a number of reasons but we have to
acknowledge number four yes there is
major x-men plans in the MCU right now
Kevin Feige confirmed back at the Marvel
phase for a comic-con panel last summer
that they are working on new x-men
movies and integrating mutants into the
MCU movies this is a clip of him
explaining how that's going to happen in
how the Marvel x-men the new
Marvel x-men will look different from
the Fox x-men.
Are you guys not looking
to go the route of a traditional x-men
titled movie for those characters
I was...mutants and X-Men
are interchangeable I just said
I just said mutants.
but yes
whatever we do will be quite different
than what's been done before.
I Also want to ask, super
quickly why Blade now and Mahershala?
They're the same answer.
Blade now because of Mahershala.
And Mahershala, because he loves Blade.
so what he's saying
means a lot of different things
when he says Marvel's x-men are going to be different
he means the characters will be
introduced in a very different way the
new core x-men MCU team will come
together in a very different way they'll
look very different isn't they'll be
different actors because they'll be
recast not including Deadpool Bryan
Reynolds will still be Deadpool don't
worry about that but physically they'll
also be wearing very different looking
costumes
obviously everybody points to the
example of Wolverines yellow comic book
costume that Hugh Jackman always laughed
at and refused to wear they even had a
whole joke in the Logan movie of how
x-23 was this big x-men fan and it grown
up reading the comics thinking that
Wolverine ran around in a yellow costume
like that and then Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine tells her no we did have
adventures but they didn't look like
that and I didn't wear a costume like
that you may remember that Kevin Feige
did have early Marvel phase 1 plans
before the first Avengers movie to
integrate x-men and even Spiderman into
the MCU there was this deleted scene of
an Iron Man post-credit scene where Nick
Fury comes to recruit Iron Man of the
Avengers initiative in the deleted scene
Nick Fury references X Man and
spider-man verbally which because it was
happening in 2008 also implies that it
would have been Tobey Maguire's
spider-man 2 crossover with the Avengers
and this was all for the first Avengers
movie.
As if gamma accidents, radioactive bug bits and assorted mutants weren't enough.
I have to deal with a spoiled brat,
Who doesn't play well with others
and wants to keep all his toys to himself
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury.
Director of SHIELD
I'm here to talk to you about the Avenger Initiative
Well, what are we avenging?
Whatever the hell we want.
The reason why there was no
x-men Avengers crossover back then or
even spider-man avenged
crossover is because at the time Kevin
Feige couldn't reach a deal with Fox or
Sony for the characters took him more
than 10 years but were finally there we
finally got x-men we finally got
spider-man back currently there is some
x-men stuff happening in the Wan
division episodes that are going to be
airing later this year I'll explain that
in a second
number three though Henry Cavill
can't play Wolverine practically mostly
because he's locked down under contract
for The Witcher Netflix for multiple
years and multiple seasons toss a coin
to your Witcher he did a great job
during season one toss a coin there are
all kinds of compilation videos out
there of him grunting angrily for hours
and dropping f-bombs
and I know a lot of people are also
claiming that he couldn't play Wolverine
because he's so huge
he's literally massive I don't consider
that a knock against him potentially
playing someone like Wolverine I mean
Hugh Jackman was over six feet tall and
he was a great Wolverine if you're not a
big comic book reader though the reason
why a lot of people complain about
Wolverine being too tall is because in
the comics he's supposed to be closer to
five three which is tiny by comparison
to people like Hugh Jackman who are way
over 6 feet if you weren't around for it
way back when they first cast Hugh
Jackman people complain for that very
same reason and if you can believe it
when they were getting ready for that
first Fox x-men movie back in 2000 the
most popular fan cast for the Wolverine
character was Bob Hoskins so it just
goes to show you that internet fan
casting does not always lead to the best
pairings of actors with characters just
because an actor looks like a character
doesn't mean that they'll be good in the
role or that the movie will be good you
also have to keep in mind that Henry
Cavill still wants to be Superman at DC
and if he were to do any kind of role no
matter how small at Marvel that would be
the nail in the coffin to him never
being Superman again number two the
other big red flag and those rumors
about Wolverine should be that he's
going to appear for the first time in
Captain Marvel 2 a space-based character
why would Wolverine of all people of
debut in a Captain Marvel movie it just
sounds ridiculous those two characters
don't have any real comic-book history
together they've only loosely interacted
during big crossovers there are a
billion other Marvel characters that
would be a better fit for Captain Marvel
- like giving adult
Rambow her comic book powers after she
shows up in one division as an adult
she's working as an agent of sword for
Nick Fury during the events of the one
division episodes don't know exactly
what she's doing and we don't know if
she has powers yet but then there's also
the blue Marvel character also fan
favorite comic book character who just
been a couple years in the Ultimate
Comics in outer space with Captain
Marvel if you don't want to wait for the
first full blown Marvel x-men movie and
Marvel phase 5 to introduce Wolverine
again a Wolverine versus Hulk movie
would probably be the best place to put
him because he debuted in the comics for
the very first time in the Incredible
Hulk comics so why not introduce him in
a Hulk movie in number 1 the current
x-men stuff right now that's happening
in the MCU on wan division is through
Scarlet Witch and visions comic book
children the twins Wiccan and speed that
they're doing on the TV show you all saw
the Wanda vision trailer there's a
couple of scenes where they jump forward
in time through the decades as if
they're living in a couple of different
sitcoms through the years she starts out
in black and white in a 1950s sitcom
looking like Donna Reed or the Dick Van
Dyke Show where she gets married a
vision when they jumped forward into the
70s in a very Brady Bunch looking house
she's super pregnant with the twins then
they jump into the 80s and it looks kind
of like family ties the twins were in
bassinets looking like they're
levitating their pacifiers with their
powers then they jump forward into the
90s and it looks more like Roseanne and
it seems like there's a bunch of kid
drawings on the fridge like they become
grade schoolers in their much older
Kevin Feige said that they're going
full-blown comic-book scarlet which
during the series so I think it's
implied that she's going to help create
these realities and then once it seems
like they're going to crumble she
refuses to let the children die with the
reality and finds a way to bring them
back into the real world that way you
have a Wiccan in speed that can then go
on to crossover with any future Young
Avengers project or any other Disney
Plus series or movies that you would
want to put them in so that's our
full-blown x-men stuff happening inside
the blonds division series but obviously
a lot of people just want to know where
the core x-men characters like Cyclops
Wolverine Jean Grey Professor X Magneto
when are they going to show up so there
is x-men stuff happening during Marvel
phase 4 but just don't expect to see
Wolverine for a long time and don't
expect it to be Henry Cavill when he
does
show up so if it wasn't clear from my
video I'm saying that the Henry Cavill
Wolverine rumors are probably not true
everyone let me know in the comments
when do you want them to do a new
version of Wolverine in the MCU and
who's the actor you want to be that new
bull Vereen I've got a couple other
Marvel phase 4 videos that I'm working
on the venom 2 trailer will be dropping
in the next month or two they'll be a
bunch more Morbius trailers and more
spider-man crossover Easter eggs so
everyone click here for my brand new
spider-man 3 video and click here for
all my new Avengers infinity Saga
deleted scenes thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!